talking about serious we are seeing the
biggest one-day jump in coronavirus just
in the u.s. census outbreak began more
than 140 people lost their lives
yesterday bringing the death toll to
over 590 in this country the number of
reported cases in the US has now risen
to more than 46,000 a new CBS News poll
says nearly three-quarters of Americans
72% believe it will take months or
longer for this virus to be contained
the corona virus has also pushed the
American economy to the brink for that
reason President Trump is now suggesting
he may be running out of patience with
measures meant to slow the virus as
Congress continues to fight over a
bailout package nowhere has been hit
harder in America than the New York
metro area around a quarter of the
country's coronavirus cases are in New
York City that's where our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is David
these numbers are causing at least one
other state to take action Anthony good
morning that's right the governor of
Florida has said listen if you're coming
to our state from New York
you need to quarantine for 14 days and
some people are giving the governor heat
saying the Florida governor should
declare a stay at home order statewide
you've got the Governor of Puerto Rico
who said anyone coming from anywhere to
our island needs to quarantine for 14
days and I want to give you a sense of
what some of the other states the
smaller ones are going through I talked
to a hospital CEO in Louisiana who said
David we need masks so bad I was on the
phone with somebody's brothers brothers
sisters friend who connected me with a
lady who usually sells perfume that she
gets from China but now she's getting
masks and we're buying them from her
that is what our top level medical
professionals are dealing with in order
to get our frontline workers the
equipment they need the governor of New
York Andrew Cuomo toured Manhattan's
Javits Center Monday it will soon be
converted to a temporary 1000 bed
facility but the governor says that
won't be enough we have 53,000 hospital
beds
we are projecting a possible need of
110,000 beds
I've ordered today the hospitals that
they must increase their capacity by 50%
in Walnut Creek California nurses at a
Kaiser Hospital rallied over the
shortage of personal protective
equipment
I see nurses go home in tears because
they feel like they've been exposed or
potentially exposed to something here
the hospital insists it is providing
equipment which is in line with current
scientific and public health standards
the US government admits it only has a
fraction of the 300 million n95 mask
stockpile that it needs for the medical
workers to protect themselves
Valley View Hospital in Glenwood Springs
Colorado is making their own surgical
masks to wear over the FDA approved in
95 masks which the nurses have been told
they only get one and they have to reuse
it health care workers in California the
governor says the state needs an
additional 50 thousand beds to treat the
sick off the coast of California the
Navy hospital ship mercy left San Diego
headed for Los Angeles with 1000 beds
and nine staffed operating rooms the
idea is to use the ship to treat people
who were not infected with kovat 19 if
you need more proof that this virus
knows no age back in New York City 26
year old yoga teacher Fiona Lowenstein
says she had no underlying medical
conditions but was still hospitalized
for Kovan 19 she lost her appetite and
was struggling to breathe she's home now
but she says things are by no means back
to normal smell I'm having GI problems I
lost a lot of weight in that first week
that I have not been able to put back on
what's the most direct pointed candid
thing you want to say to people your age
I think I want to say that at some point
during this crisis
we have all not taken it seriously Fiona
wrote an op-ed in the New York Times
basically targeting people her age in
their mid-20s
saying hear my story and understand this
is serious for people who are as young
as we are I want you to know that the
Pentagon says five military field
hospitals will be set up around the
country one is going to the Seattle area
another one is set to arrive in New York
this week that military support is
Harding but people do need to take this
seriously David thank you very much